on a daily basis I say no to something
if it feels like a mediocre maybe a
mediocre yes it's just a no I'm not
binary about a lot of things but that's
a that that's a binary approach that has
been useful for me I think asking what a
yes looks and feels like is important
because once you've achieved some
element of success sometimes there's
just something that other things that
happen in lock step it was like oh if
you've done this then you obviously have
to do this and if if you've written a
book then you obviously have to do this
next and it's other people's IDE
of what the next Finish Line is or what
the the next expectation is but I often
have to check myself and ask like what
does a yes signing on the dotted line
accepting the proposal the business
partner the Romantic partner whatever it
is what does the yes look and feel like
so you mentioned me manifesting um my
husband and I I feel like I kind of did
but one of the things that I would dream
and write about was what a Sunday
morning looked like at our
house